at launch there are two options when it
comes to new generation xbox consoles
the more powerful and equipped xbox
series x or the more affordable but
somewhat limited xbox series
s i've already delivered my review of
the series x but what does the series s
offer well it's a cute and compact
console that'll play next gen xbox games
and for a relatively cheap entry price
of 300 bucks
it's a sleek system that comes with many
of the same great features of the
beefier series x
with some compromises that you'll need
to consider let's first talk about
performance the rdna 2 gpu and zen 2 cpu
from amd that are packed into the series
s
are scaled down versions of what's in
the series x it's all part of the same
tech architecture
microsoft's aim for the series s is to
hit 1440p
resolution instead of full 4k which is
still ambitious all things considered
and when playing optimized games on the
smaller console
it's genuinely impressive gears 5 looks
and runs great
it might not have the same clarity and
the details might not shine through
as distinctly as they do on the series x
but you still get a consistent 60fps
at what looks to be 1440p the series s
also has room to do 120 fps if
optimizations allow for it
and you have the proper 120hz display
this is the case in gears 5 multiplayer
forza horizon 4 is noteworthy as well
since it can hit 60fps
and maintain its fantastic visual flare
at what looks to be a solid 1440p
resolution on a 4k tv
i can tell the image isn't as sharp as
it is on the series x but otherwise it
looks crisp
one curious case is yakuza like a dragon
as of now it actually offers
the same two graphics options as it does
on the series x albeit scaled down for
the series s hardware
high resolution mode seems to do 1440p
30fps
and normal mode looks to be 1080p at a
smooth 60fps
this could mean that we may see similar
options pop up even for series s
optimized games in the future as for
backwards compatibility the series
s essentially takes base xbox one builds
of games
and goes from there this has an impact
on what you get out of backwards
compatible games compared to the series
x
if a game is not optimized for next gen
the series x will play the
1x enhanced version however the series s
will only play the base
xbox one version meaning you'll miss out
on the enhancements that came from the
previous generation's high-end console
for example let's look at final fantasy
xv on series x you can
access the 1x enhancements which allow
you to choose to boost frame rate or
crank up the resolution
when playing on series s you simply get
the base xbox one version
that runs at a capped 30fps with its
blurry sub 1080p resolution
doom eternal is 1x enhanced and runs
great on the series x2
but it's a bit disappointing to play the
xbox one version on the series s
which caps at 900p resolution to
maintain 60fps
the series s can run back and pack games
with more stable performance
but as of now it's held back by the base
xbox one builds of games in these cases
the reasons for this are understandable
but the series s has so much power left
over
so it'll be up to developers to go back
and implement optimizations if they want
so things could improve
while the series s concedes some
graphical horsepower it doesn't skimp
out on the ssd
in terms of speed it packs the same type
of internal storage drive as the series
x so you get the same ultra fast load
times
some examples i've used in previous
coverage are final fantasy xv
the outer worlds and control which all
load from the main menu
and into gameplay in about 10 to 12
seconds yakuza like a dragon and gears 5
only take about 5 to 6
seconds the xbox one x internal drive
would take about 4 to 5 times longer
for these games to me this is a real
game changer
a practical and tangible benefit that
makes the gaming experience
closer to seamless once you get a taste
of super fast loading in games you will
not want to go back to anything lesser
where the series s makes a major cut is
in its ssd's
size the 512 gigabyte internal drive
actually comes out to 364 gigabytes
of free usable space considering the
size of games
this is not a lot of storage if you play
all of call of duty's modes well
that's a third of your drive gone now
some games actually have smaller install
sizes
specifically for the series s forza
horizon 4 takes up 71.4 gigabytes on the
series s
as opposed to 84.6 gigabytes on the
series x
and gears 5 takes up 55.1 gigabytes
down from 71.9 gigabytes this helps
somewhat but not by much
however sea of thieves chops off a lot
down to 17 gigabytes
from 46.6 gigabytes developers can
decide which assets are part of the
installation
so mileage may vary you have some
options for expanding storage though the
one terabyte seagate drive is
technically the best solution but it's
also the most expensive
at 220 bucks you'd be paying more than
you would for a series x
if you're gonna pair that with a series
s you can use external usb 3 drives to
play backwards compatible games and the
load times can be pretty quick on
external ssds
however you can't play next gen or
series s optimized games straight off
the drive
you have to transfer the install files
to internal storage which thankfully
doesn't take that long
either way if you want to move beyond
that 364 gigabyte limitation
and you don't already have an external
drive it's going to cost you
most other things stay the same in terms
of the user experience
the ui is the same it's as snappy as it
is on the series x
and quick resume works exactly as it's
intended as i've said before
suspending up to 5 or 6 games and
jumping between them in a matter of
seconds
is pretty sweet and a useful feature and
the fact that games stay suspended after
powering off the system
is cool too as we move more toward
digital distribution
the lack of a disk drive on the series s
might not be all that bad
especially considering the emphasis on
game pass for xbox's future
but those who kept their physical xbox
one and 360 games
will be out of luck with the series s or
if you use your system for entertainment
on blu-ray if that's important to you
the series s
is a no-go whereas the series x has a
sort of low-key yet imposing presence to
its design
the series s is cute maybe you think
it's a plain white box with a big fan
vent on top but considering the power it
packs and the fact that it's a next-gen
system
it's impressive it's tiny light and
sports a minimalist aesthetic
and it's literally the smallest xbox
ever overall it's nice that you can
access next-gen for 300 bucks
with a compact box like the series s an
entry level option is just cool to see
out there
moving forward games will naturally
accommodate the series s
so impressive cases like forza verizon 4
and gears 5
will be more common whether or not this
should be your system of choice for next
gen is determined by how much its
compromises affect you
and also if you care about 4k if those
things are important to you
consider saving a bit more for a series
x the series s could serve as a great
cost-effective system
that is complementary to say a
playstation or switch
if you just want to access what the
platform offers now or what's to come in
xbox's future
and if you don't mind the graphical and
storage gap this is the xbox for you
[Music]